Trascrizione: Maria Pericleous
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Quante sono le persone
che hanno lasciato veramente il segno
nella nostra vita lavorativa?
Lasciamo perdere genitori, amici, parenti
tutto quanto ferisce la sfera privata.
Pensiamo solo ed esclusivamente
alla nostra carriera.
Quante sono quelle persone
che possiamo seguire
che ci hanno dato
degli spunti, degli esempi,
che ci possono ispirare,
sia nella vita di tutti i giorni
che nello sviluppo negli anni
della nostra carriera.
Io sono stato molto fortunato.
Ho avuto a che fare con centinaia
di professionisti differenti.
Professionisti molto simili a me,
con un’estrazione molto simile alla mia,
ma anche molto differenti da me.
E di questi ne posso selezionare
penso tre o quattro.
Di sicuro li conto sulle dita di una mano.
Ma la domanda più carina è:
Come ho fatto a selezionarli?
Qual è il filtro che ho applicato
per passare da diverse centinaia
a poche unità?
Mi sono accorto
di avere riconosciuto in loro
delle caratteristiche, delle doti,
in modo molto evidente.
Doti e caratteristiche
che io ritengo fondamentali
sia nella vita di tutti i giorni
che nello sviluppo
della carriera negli anni.
Caratteristiche come la competenza.
La competenza è quella cosa quasi magica
che ci permette di sapere
quello di cui stiamo parlando.
E non è scontato.
È quella cosa che ci dà
sicurezza, autorevolezza
che ci permette di parlare
con tutte le nostre controparti,
siano essi colleghi, fornitori,
clienti, quello che volete voi.
Sapendo quello di cui stiamo parlando,
senza aver paura che ci scatti
una domanda scomoda
a cui non sappiamo rispondere,
senza la paura che questi possano
grattare sotto la superficie
senza trovare della sostanza.
Ducati Corse un po’ di anni fa,
era formata da un gruppo
di un centinaio di tecnici
con una grande passione in comune:
passione per le moto e per le competizioni
e anche un grande sogno,
quello di diventare campioni del mondo,
sogno che abbiamo anche avuto
la fortuna di veder avverato
E in quel contesto io ho conosciuto
un responsabile estremamente competente,
una persona che alimentava il suo sapere
incamerando ed elaborando
una mole di informazioni incredibile
tutti i giorni.
Tutte le sere andava a casa
con un plico di relazioni così
e tutte le mattine tornava
con lo stesso plico
corretto con le sue note a margine.
Relazioni che ovviamente
dovevamo redigere noi.
E tutta quella attenzione
e quella competenza
a me e a molti colleghi
motivava particolarmente.
Ho capito quanto fossi portato
a dare sempre il 101%
di quello che avevo.
È anche vero che però gli stessi valori
che per me erano
così importanti e motivanti
magari per il mio vicino di scrivania
erano l’esatto contrario,
gli creavano addirittura
degli stati di disagio.
Immaginatevi una riunione
in cui c’è da risolvere un problema.
Una decina di giovani ingegneri,
tutti che fanno un po’ a gara
a vedere chi è il più sveglio,
il più lesto a trovare la soluzione.
Lui ogni tanto ci lasciava sfogare un po’
e poi con la sua voce tranquilla
se ne usciva.
Guardate, il problema è questo.
Principio fisico che lo governa
è questo qua.
La formula che ci sta dietro è questa.
E scriveva su un foglio la formula
esattamente come lo possiamo trovare
sui libri dell’università.
A me personalmente è capitato
con la formula che governa
il serraggio e il diserraggio
di un giunto filettato.
(Risate)
Ovvero
perché ad avvitare una vite
si fa un po’ più fatica che a svitarla.
Il concetto, state sicuri,
che mi è rimasto ben impresso,
me lo porto ancora dietro.
Però è anche vero
che forse può anche non essere
un direttore particolarmente illuminato
ad ispirarci tutti i giorni.
Può anche essere quel collega dotato
di un particolare entusiasmo.
L’entusiasmo è quello che ci porta
a imparare, tutti i giorni,
qualcosa di più, qualcosa di diverso,
perché abbiamo trovato
qualcosa di interessante.
È quello che abbiamo qua oggi, se volete.
Pensate a quel collega
che vi mette di buonumore,
anche solo a trovarlo
alla macchinetta del caffè.
Quello con lo spirito creativo,
tanto innovativo,
quello che è di casa sua
allo stesso modo
per le vie di Reggio Emilia,
che è la sua città,
o tra i padiglioni zeppi di tecnologia
del CES di Las Vegas.
E un giorno nel pieno del suo spirito
ci chiese di scrivere su un post-it
quello che pensavamo di lui.
Qual era la nostra impressione
nei suoi confronti.
Io non mi ricordo cosa scrissi.
Però mi ricordo esattamente
cosa recitava un altro.
Diceva: “Tu sei un raggio di sole
in una giornata grigia”.
E non un fu un lato poetico
a colpirmi più di tanto,
fu il fatto che rispondeva esattamente
alla descrizione di entusiasmo
che io avevo in mente.
Perché l’entusiasmo
è quello che ci permette di vedere
delle sfumature di colore,
dei dettagli che altrimenti
magari si perderebbero nel grigiore
di una giornata normale.
Ma si può imparare tanto
anche da persone
completamente diverse da noi.
A me è capitato
con un atleta professionista,
e vi assicuro che io sono
completamente diverso
da un atleta professionista.
Un pilota di livello mondiale,
un pilota arrivato molto tardi alla gloria
dopo i 30 anni,
che mi ha colpito addirittura
per due caratteristiche,
la perseveranza e l’empatia.
La perseveranza è quella che ci impone
di continuare ad allenare i nostri talenti
che ci impedisce di adagiarcisi sopra.
Lui fu un esempio,
perché mentre tanti altri già vincevano,
lui faceva dei lavori normali
per pagare la sua passione
e per finanziare il suo sogno
di arrivare un giorno
a dimostrare quanto valesse.
Alcuni gli dicevano già prima dei 30 anni:
“sei vecchio, lascia stare”.
Lui ha iniziato a vincere dopo i 30,
ma anche quando aveva già
vinto dei mondiali
continuava ad allenarsi e ad affrontare
le gare e tutti gli impegni
con una tenacia e una professionalità
fuori dal comune.
Ma.
Mi colpì particolarmente
anche per le doti umane,
non solo per la sua perseveranza.
Doti umane che si possono riassumere
in una parola: empatia.
L’empatia è quella
che ci permette di capire
il punto di vista della nostra controparte
indipendentemente da quanto diversi siamo.
Immaginatevi la gara di casa
del mondiale superbike.
Autodromo di Monza,
anno penso 2008, doveva essere.
Lui parte dalla pole position,
e in gara 1 ha già portato a casa
un ottimo podio, che su quel circuito
per la nostra moto è un gran risultato.
Gara 2 parte e, come sempre,
è lì a battagliare nelle prime posizioni.
Passano sei o sette giri
e dai monitor dei box
iniziamo a vedere un accenno di fumo
che esce dal suo motore.
Un altro paio di giri
e l’incubo diventa realtà.
Imbocca la pit lane e parcheggia la moto
dentro il box ritirandosi dalla gara.
A quel punto,
nella drammaticità del momento,
perché lui era in lotta per il mondiale,
quindi aveva perso molto
nella drammaticità di quel momento.
Assistetti a una scena
che mi ricordo ancora.
Era la gara di casa,
e quindi erano presenti
tutte le autorità della nostra azienda,
e vidi il maggior azionista
che guardò severamente
il direttore generale,
che guardò il responsabile del progetto,
che guardò il meccanico
che aveva montato il motore.
Il meccanico, poverino,
si guardava in giro
ma non c’era nessuno
a cui passare la patata,
e quindi guardava il motore
cercando di capire
cosa fosse andato male.
E non mi ricordo se questo pilota
avesse ancora la tuta di pelle addosso,
o se da buon australiano
avesse già gli infradito ai piedi.
Ma mi ricordo perfettamente
che ragguinse quel meccanico
gli diede una pacca sulla spalla
e gli disse: “Tranquillo,
queste sono le gare,
una volta si perde,
la prossima la vinciamo”.
E alla faccia di quelli
che gli davano del vecchio
prima dei 30 anni,
alla fine dell’anno
si porta a casa il terzo Mondiale,
alla soglia dei 40.
Sempre tornando alla perseveranza.
Quindi senza alzare un po’
il tema della giornata,
non è certo sulla mia divisione
che vorrei porre
la vostra attenzione oggi.
Ma è su quella di tutte queste persone
che con comportamenti e atteggiamenti
così affini a dei valori che per noi
sono così importanti,
fungono da esempio,
sia nella vita lavorativa
di tutti i giorni
che nello sviluppo della nostra carriera.
E come vi dicevo prima,
io finora posso contarli tranquillamente
con le dita di una mano.
Però continuo a tenere
gli occhi sempre ben aperti
e sono ben contento di cominciare
a usare la seconda.
E voi oggi quante dita potete utilizzare
per contare questo tipo di persone?
Grazie a tutti.
(Applausi)